I can feel the juice losing all the
sides of my face every guy has his own
pan guy I know nothing about what my
parents love this and I'm only doing
this video so that they don't disown me
but yeah I was forbidden from ever
having fun and I don't know why like a
pawn table is usually the only table in
an Indian wedding that is more crowded
than the buffet table you just got
concept it it's like I would drop it in
anything and it tastes good this awesome
Romero it's like mint chocolate but new
feels smooth sinewy do of chocolate this
isn't as horrible as I expected it to be
very damn heavy though I feel like
really full already
this one leaf is greener than the other
song assuming this is will be better we
relaxed it's light its coconutty no
weird
explosion nonsense [ __ ] going inside
I say it the whole thing like I enjoyed
it you can't use water have to keep
doing oh I can do a lot of work on
that's a rose petal paste why can't they
just get rid of these leaves and have
the rest of it this is the pond I used
to get my grandmother I wish lip buy a
cup of tea Dana mmm
what bad neither why it's the most
popular in India well momen de elect may
be tasted like ass and that's the most
professional way I can describe it it's
just like more and more sand in my mouth
my whole mouth will become really dry
after having this why am i eating ponder
I'd rather eat sand either really bitter
aftertaste
yeah really build Ober it's kinda nice
this is the fun with the tobacco and one
you see bent out this is great god this
a strong gone now and like the taste I
don't think I'm going to get this taste
out of my mouth for a while Oh God
it may be the most famous but sorry is
the worst your duty about it is just
being attention to a fingers for a
moment this is what we have done this
kind of made me miss my dad and all the
power now things it has to be an
acquired taste upon was a little chewy
but I'm definitely not having fun solo